so we've defined two random variables
here the first random variable X is the
weight of the cereal in a random box of
our favorite cereal Mathies or random
closed box of our favorite cereal
Matthies and we know a few other things
about it we know what the expected value
of X is it is equal to 16 ounces in fact
we tell it to us on a box they say you
know net weight 16 ounces now when you
see that on a cereal box it doesn't mean
that every box is going to be exactly 16
ounces remember you have a discrete
number of these flakes in here they
might have slightly different densities
slightly different shapes depending how
they get packed into this volume so
there is some variation which we can
measure with standard deviation so the
standard deviation let's just say for
the sake of argument for the random
variable X is zero point eight ounces
and just to build our intuition a little
bit later in this video let's say that
this the random variable X is always
stays constrained within a within a
range that if it goes above a certain
weight or below a certain weight then
the company that produces it just throws
out that box and so let's say that our
random variable X is always greater than
or equal to fifteen ounces and it is
always less than or equal to 17 ounces
just for argument this will help us
build our intuition later on now
separately let's consider a bold we're
always going to sitt consider the same
sized bowl let's consider this a 4 ounce
bowl because the expected value of y if
you took a random one of these bowls
always the same Bowl and if or if you
took the same bowl and you someone
filled it with Mathies there's expected
weight of the Mathies in that bowl is
going to be 4 ounces but once again
there's going to be some variation
depends who filled it in how it packed
in did they shake it before while they
were filling it there could be all sorts
of things that could make some variation
here and so for the sake of argument
let's say that variation can be measured
by standard deviation and it's 0.6
ounces and let's say whoever the bowl
fillers are they are also they don't
like bowls that are too heavy or too
light and so they'll also throw out
bowls
we can say that why can its maximum
value that'll ever take on is five
ounces and the minimum value that it
could ever take on let's say it is three
ounces so given all of this information
what I want to do is let's just say I
take a random box of Mathies and I take
a random filled Bowl and I want to think
about the combined weight in the closed
box and the fill Bowl so what I want to
think about is really X plus y I want to
think about the sum of the random
variables so in previous videos we
already know that the expected value of
this is just going to be the sum of the
expected values of each of the random
variables so it would be the expected
value of X plus the expected value of y
and so it would be 16 plus 4 ounces in
this case this would be equal to 20
ounces but what about the variation can
we just add up the standard deviations
if I want to figure out the standard
deviation of X plus y how can I do this
well it turns out that you can't just
add up the standard deviations but you
can add up the variances so it is the
case that the variance of X plus y is
equal to the variance of X plus the
variance of Y and so this is going to
have an X right over here X and then we
have plus y and our Y and actually both
of these assume independent random
variables so it assumes assumes x and y
are independent I'm going to write it in
caps in a future video I'm going to get
a give you a hopefully a better
intuition for why this must be true that
they're independent in order to make
this claim right over here I'm not going
to prove it in this video
but we could build a little bit of
intuition here for each of these random
variables we have a range of two ounces
over which this random variable can take
and that's true for both of them but
what about this sum well this sum here
could get as high as so let me write it
this way so
X plus y X plus y what's the maximum
value that it could take on well if you
get a heavy version of each of these
then it's going to be seventeen plus
five so this has to be less than 22
ounces that's going to be greater than
or equal to well what's the lightest
possible scenario well you could get a
15 ounce er here and a three answer here
and it is 18 ounces and so notice now
the variation for the sum is larger we
have a range that this thing can take on
now of four while the range for each of
these was just two or another way you
could think about it is these upper and
lower ends of the range are further from
the mean then these upper and lower ends
of the range were from their respective
means so hopefully this gives you an
intuition for why this makes sense but
let me ask you another question
what if I were to say what about the
variance what about the variance of X
minus y what would this be would you
would you subtract the variances of each
of the random variables here well let's
just do the exact same exercise let's
take X minus y X minus y and think about
it what would be the lowest value that X
minus y could take on well the lowest
value is if you have a low X and you
have a high Y so it'd be 15 minus 5 so
this would be 10 right over here that
would be the lowest value that you could
take on and what would be the highest
value well the highest values if you
have a high X and a low Y so 17 minus 3
is 14 so notice just in the case of just
as if we saw in this case of the sum
even in the difference your variability
seems to have increased this is still
going to be this the end of the extremes
are still further than the mean of the
difference the mean of the difference
would be 16 minus 4 is 12 these these
extreme values are 2 away from the 12
and this is just to give us an intuition
once again it's not a rigorous proof so
it actually turns out that in either
case when you're taking the variance of
X plus y or X minus y you would sum the
variance
assuming X and y are independent
variables now with that out of the way
let's just calculate the standard
deviation of X plus y well we know this
let me just write it using this Sigma
notation so another way of writing the
variance of X plus y is to write the
standard deviation of X plus y squared
and that's going to be equal to the
variance of X plus the variance of Y now
what is the variance of X what's the
standard deviation of x squared 0.8
squared this is zero point six four zero
point six for the standard deviation of
Y is zero point six use square to get
the variance that's zero point three six
you add these two up and you are going
to get one so the variance of the sum is
one and then if you take the square root
of both of these you get the standard
deviation of the sum is also going to be
one and that just happened to work out
because we're dealing with the scenario
where the variance where the square root
of one is well one well so this
hopefully builds your intuition whether
we are adding or subtracting two
independent random variables the
variance of that sum or the difference
the variability will increase in the
next video we'll go into some depth
talking about getting an intuition for
why independence is an important
condition for making this statement this
claim